Wow that was a heck of a thing so I'm
not sure I've really done this before
this is kind of a look back at 2018 but
not look back at the movies not look
back the TV shows just look back for me
and the channel and everything that went
on because it has been a punkers year
like in a good way though so like where
do I start
well I launched the patreon this year
which is going well it's it's got steady
growth on it and it helps I mean that
there are tangible things that have come
about from it I got a teleprompter that
I have already used for some of the
videos that I want to actually script so
you know that that has come up and been
put to use the thumbnails the reason I'm
able to have these thumbnails is I'm
able to pay my thumbnail guy Joel and
the reason I'm able to be I'm able to
afford to do that is because of the
patreon because I'm not gonna ask him to
crank out a thumbnail a day at no
recompense which brings up the fact that
I've been doing daily videos since May
and enjoying it and not burning out on
it which is nuts and awesome and coming
back to Joel like that was great like he
he literally just reached out to me he
just reached out and said hey you know
your thumbnails you know what about
something like this and he kind of gotta
give me a trial run he likes he for
about a week he just I told him what I
was gonna do send him a reference photo
for me for like you know my thoughts and
for each of those and he'd put something
together and I was like okay I would
love
you keep doing this we got to figure out
an arrangement and now we have and
Joel's awesome
Joel seraphic especially for turnaround
time because you need to realize that
like I do have a docket I have a plan
for what things I'm gonna do so I can
send him stuff in advance but then
there's stuff that happens that I didn't
know was gonna happen before like a new
trailer drops or what have you and I
gotta turn this stuff around quick which
means he has to turn around quick and
Joel is awesome I've got new intros cuz
I ran the contest and you guys submitted
and that was astonishing that was
amazing I love these I love using them
you started to see my partner Liz she
started appearing this year for reviews
and lists and a handful of other things
you'll see more of her next year as well
didn't get to see as much of the sort of
the old crew you know Ryan and Paul
being the big ones like schedules are
just harder to wrangle these days
especially given you know the speedy
turnaround time I have on a lot of these
Ryan I am able to still get every now
and then Paul I I would be surprised if
we see Paul again anytime soon but guys
just got so much going on that this is
really hard to to schedule time and get
it to work if I can get him back
I will he's gonna stay on the logo so
that's not going anywhere don't worry
about that but yeah the it's been great
having Liz on she's enjoyed being on
your guys's response to her being here
has been wonderful and welcoming which
was a relief I'm not gonna lie she was a
little bit nervous about how people were
gonna feel about her showing up but you
guys have embraced her and that that was
that was heartening for her and for me
I tripled my no I more than tripled my
subscriber base because I started this
year with ten thousand and I'm ending it
with ice I mean I'm recording this a
little earlier than the day goes up so I
don't know what the exact number or will
be but at the time of recording I'm over
31 so that was amazing
could they like
this is a subscriber number I was not
sure I'd know Eileen ever thought I'd
hit this like 10,000 was a number that
I'm like maybe someday and then hitting
that last year was that was mind-blowing
enough but to see that it's kept up and
not plateaued
like I would I've had ongoing projects
and social media stuff sort of start
here and then just plateau after a while
and you know stop growing and I've kind
of been waiting for that to happen here
and it hasn't I still kind of astounded
by that but that's amazing that's
incredible I think in many ways though
the the biggest thing is something that
I got to get a little bit more personal
on which is that back in January back in
the start of this year I came out on
this channel as gender-fluid
which was something that I was part of
me was very afraid to do because I
didn't know what the reaction would be
and the reaction was nothing but
supportive like I can look back at the
comments on that video even the people
who are like you know I kind of don't
get it but like the harshest reaction I
got was I mean I don't really care about
that I'm here for Europeans like that
was as harsh as a god that's still
amazing to me that's still awesome and
then to not only come out but you know
let my hair down now on a monthly basis
talking about lgbtq+ representation
which is a topic that I it it's very
it's freeing it's it's uplifting for me
to be able to talk about that and know
that you know you guys are okay we're
gonna be talking about that on a monthly
basis and it's great because these are
things I want to talk
and I don't want to be afraid to talk
about them and you've helped me feel not
scared to tackle these things in the
response to all those have been amazing
there's some of my most viewed stuff
which you know if I was more views and
growth centric and focused maybe I'd do
more of that stuff trying to trying to
you know mastermind faster growth but I
don't want to do that because I've got a
lot of other stuff to do
and also like the the pace that I want
to do these that I I put I mentioned
scripting like most of those not all
like not like the first big one the
queerbaiting one that wasn't scripted I
had notes but that wasn't scripted but a
lot of them since then have been and I
because I want to pick my words
carefully for a lot of that stuff when I
talk about it and you know that more
than one a month like for as long as
this isn't my actual bills paying job if
that that's where it's that's where it's
got to stay you know to make sure that I
that I end up with the results that I
want when I talk about those we had a
new doctor this year so I've gotten to
talk about that which is which it's been
exciting to talk about dealing with the
fandom around it that's a little bit of
a different ball of wax but I like I
always enjoy talking about new Doctor
Who episodes that's always been
something that I like and I've now I'm
now doing more Doctor Who content which
was something that I was shaky about for
a long time but I know most of you found
me through Doctor Who stuff so you know
I'm doing the overdue Doctor Who reviews
this is a lot of fun I'm and sort of
even separate from this I like my book
got published a shameless plug hold on
[Music]
yeah since my hair is down there's a
link for this down in the description
but yeah like that I post a book that I
can hold in my hand it's just on a shelf
that's weird that's great but that's
weird
20:18 has been an unabashedly incredible
year for me it has had so much go on I
you know and I'm continuing to perform I
do burlesque numbers I debuted oh my god
how many numbers that I debut this year
I debuted quite a few whoo
and I got to perform at Vermont pride I
I got accepted into the Vermont
burlesque Festival which I'll be doing
next month so I'll you know all of that
is still going on which I love doing
it's the number of things that went well
for me in 2018 almost feels unfair
because I know a lot of people that
allows a year like a lot of close
friends went through hell in 2018 and I
mean part of me can't help but feel a
little guilty because I'm like did I SAP
the good luck from other people was I
good fortune vampire this year because
I'm not trying to be like that's how
good my 2018 was it was really amazing
and it is what it is partially thanks to
all of you being here watching
commenting supporting if you hop to do
that yeah what a year that's that's one
for the books
that one was so that's sort of me doing
my own personal wrap-up for 2018
separate from talking about best movies
or you know any of that stuff
that stuff's coming don't worry about it
but how was 2018 for you what were the
good things what were the bad things
whatever you want to share feel free so
whatever your thoughts
on this year that we have passed oh and
like when I say it was a great year I am
talking on a personal level like I if I
step back from my own life I can look at
the bigger picture and go okay yeah but
you know I'm not a news or political
channel so I don't want to talk about
bad so yeah how was 2018 for you
personally I mean if you want to share a
bigger scope you can but like that's
kind of what I'm after it's what this
video was it's what I'd like to hear
from you so however it was drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it whole bunch of stuff you can do
because there's button in zoo and
there's links including one to the
patreon if you feel like helping me
there cuz every little bit does help as
cheesy as that is but you know what you
don't want to click on that that's okay
there's other links to don't want to
click on them that's fine as well
because at the end of the day you are
the council and I just run the meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]